- [Gary] Thank you.
- Two floors you have here, you said.
- [Gary] Two floors and then we have LA
and London and Singapore's opening up.
- Wow.
- [Gary] It's really happening.
- [Sampson] Wow, that's amazing.
- It's real amazing, thank you.
You know what I'm buying up like crazy?
Like crazy.
This is my favorite thing
I'm buying right now.
- [Sharlee] Football cards.
- No, it's--
- [Sharlee] Colin's card.
- [Sampson] Colin's card, yeah.
- I am buying so many Colin
Kaepernick rookie cards.
- [Sharlee] 'Cause you
know they're gonna--
- 'Cause the sports card
market is pricing it
as him being an inactive player.
- [Sampson] Right, but it's--
- But I think he's a cultural icon.
So like in 15 years.
- [Sampson] It's gonna blow up, yeah.
It is, it is.
- You like that concept?
- [Crew Member] Yep.
- I'm telling you this is my favorite one.
You know how it started?
I started, in the safe, if I
my password now I'd be good.
In my safe behind you
I have like eight Jackie
Robinson rookie cards.
- [Sharlee] Get out of here.
- Uh-huh, so I've been buying up
1948 Jackie Robinson
rookie cards like crazy.
Because I literally, by
the way where I'm going
with all this, I think sports cards
are about to become
cultural like sneakers.
- [Sampson] Right, right.
- [Sharlee] My son, he just yesterday
was waiting for Amazon to come.
He had bought for his birthday, he bought.
- How old?
- [Sharlee] He's eight.
- Yep.
- [Sharlee] He's, I mean
we have baseball cards
all over our house.
- Has that always been the
case or is this just starting?
- No, well.
- Obviously your dynamics
a little different.
- [Sharlee] He's been doing it for awhile.
But like he's really into it.
- We live?
We live with YouTube?
What episode is it?
- [Andy] 316.
- This how we're gonna do it.
We'll do some improv, we'll go into it
and do some calls as well.
- [Sampson] Okay.
- You will follow, it's very easy.
Three what?
(Sampson laughs)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is Episode 316 of
the "Ask Gary Vee Show".
And I'm really excited about this episode
for a couple of reasons.
One, I've been on vacation for two weeks
which means I've so much pent up energy
that I wanna get out into the world,
so I'm excited about that.
But more importantly, we have a really,
really interesting show for you.
If you're watching on,
where are you taking the
phone calls from, Andy?
- [Andy] Facebook and YouTube.
- Okay, so Instagram I know
you're watching over there.
If you wanna get a question
in, you're gonna have to go
to Facebook or YouTube
where we're live on both
those platforms and put
your phone number in.
Andy's gonna grab some phone calls.
But before we get into all that stuff.
I'm gonna let these two lovely
guests introduce themselves,
give you a little context
about who they are
and what their book's about.
I got some question and then
you'll have some questions.
Thanks for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Lady's first.
- Okay, I'm Sharlee Jeter.
I'm co-author of "The Stuff"
but also President of
the Turn 2 Foundation.
I work for my brother,
Derek which most of you know, or may know.
And I'm just excited to be here.
Thanks for having us.
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- Yeah, Sampson Davis.
I'm an ER physician, a
co-author of "The Stuff".
I have written a few other books as well
and travel the country and speak often
and just excited to be here.
- So let's first, before we go even deeper
into you individually
just 'cause of the way you guys set it up.
What is "The Stuff" about?
What is this book about?
- Well "The Stuff" is an inner-fortitude.
It's something that we believe
every person is born with
is the ability to overcome huge obstacles
and challenges in life.
We think far too often,
especially young people,
but everybody goes into
a situation with the idea
that they already cannot accomplish it.
And so what we wanted
to do with this book--
- Have lost before they've started.
- Exactly, and so--
- Is that conditioning from
parents, environment, DNA?
- [Both] All of the above.
- Yeah, one of the things that--
- I'm just making my plea
to be the third author in The Stuff Two.
(both laugh)
- [Sampson] It's fine, done deal.
- Real quick I know I'm
just going improv here,
do you remember the
"Spaceballs" the movie?
- [Both] Yes.
- Do you know that they had a sequel?
It never got made
but it was called "Spaceballs
Three, The Search for Two".
(both laugh)
I still think that's the
coolest shit I'd ever heard.
Anyways, sorry, I still think
that's the greatest subtitle to a sequel.
- [Sampson] That's right.
Do the third before the second.
- Nonetheless, all of the above.
- Right, so what we wanted
to do is we went around,
we interviewed different people
who had overcome humongous obstacles.
- And for everybody who's
listening because it was funny
yesterday a woman came up to me
during a charity basketball game.
She submitted something
for our K-Swiss campaign
and she's like I submitted my challenge
and then video came out
and those were real,
I was like talking about like
having two knee surgeries
and people were like
talking about real shit.
Just for context for like what
are some of the challenges
that people overcame in this book?
- I mean we have many stories.
One we share our personal stories
and challenges that we faced.
We have a person in the book
who was burned over 90% of his body.
He was given greater
than 100% mortality rate
at age, he was a teenager,
and his mother asked him,
"Do you wanna live or do you wanna die?
"And if you wanna live you have to fight."
and so he chose to fight, obviously
and he survived and he overcame.
Given a mortality rate of
100% that's almost miraculous
that he was able to kind
of overcome the situation.
- From a medical standpoint,
I have a question
I have a feeling this is gonna
be a tough thing to answer.
But I'm you just inspired me to ask
and it's something I think about so much.
How underrated is the brain
in our current society
when it comes to genuinely, you know,
obviously, there's diseases and things
that are just it's kind of math thing.
But like I'm fascinated
by what you just said.
Because I'm uncomfortable
in how much I believe it.
And where I'm going with
that is I just think
you can will shit into existence.
- I mean your attitude
is a big, big part of it
and how us sort of approach it,
your confidence in seeing
that glass as half full
and really believing
that you can persevere
and overcome your situation
is a big component of it.
Now, granted there are medical conditions
that are challenging and--
- If somebody rips your
heart out of your body
like Mortal Combat even
though I'd sitting there
being like I'm not gonna die.
I'm probably gonna die at that point.
- [Sampson] At that point, right.
You can see yourself,
you can see your heart
and you know how it's gonna end, but.
(he laughs)
But keep in mind--
- How advanced are the
studies in literally
that person laying there
where they're a 50/50,
a 70/30 not gonna make it.
I've never even heard mortality rates.
So like, you know but
like that 70/30 person
has there been enough
data on the woman or guy
that laid there and said,
fuck this I'm gonna win
and what that variable is versus
what most people hear is like,
oh, my god 70%, I'm done.
Has there, is there any advance--
- I mean the studies have shown,
I don't know any particular study,
but I do know that studies have shown
is all about your attitude.
I mean, of course, the
medical condition is variable.
So the medical condition
or whatever you have
and been diagnosed with, the situation
it's all about your
attitude and your approach
and your conditioning.
If you're gonna choose to
exercise and believe and hope
and that you're gonna overcome
and beat this situation.
Yes, it will happen.
Now, if you're gonna sit back.
You're diagnosed with something
well I'm not gonna take
this medicine, right, then--
- You're talking about
something super interesting.
You know like, I don't
know any of the details
of the Steve Jobs thing.
- [Sampson] Right, right, right.
- Like the classic headline reading.
Like I remember thinking, like hearing
like maybe he did some alternative
stuff right from the get
and I was like, hmm,
I'm that kind of person.
So let's make sure I
don't make that kind of,
like I took note of that to your point.
You know it's very interesting
we're having this conversation.
It kind of makes me
think about all the shit
that I pump out into the world.
Which is like look, everybody
who's listening right now,
to make it contextual for you,
you hae a certain level of
natural entrepreneurial talent.
No different than sports talent.
No different than anything else.
But the perspective you
deploy changes the outcome
to the maximum of what that is.
- And at times, I mean
even with this stuff
at times it may not be at
where you want it to be
but it's nurturing.
It's developing and it's
every day processing
and putting energy into it.
And as you do so, then your belief
and the growth of what you can achieve
and how you can overcome
and how you can persevere
whether it's medical,
personal life, professional,
it starts to develop and take flight.
- Who were you as a kid?
- [Sharlee] Me?
- Yep.
(she chuckles)
- I was a tomboy.
But I was somebody, I was
raised, a very close-knit family.
Had parents that told us we
could accomplish anything.
I tell you I was very fortunate
because they wouldn't let us listen
to the outside world, you know, and hear.
But also, too, you know,
you can only be shielded for so long.
You have to go out into the real world
which is what I was hit with
when I went off to college.
- Did they do a good, you know it's funny
'cause I saw Andy react
to like not hearing the outside world.
It's something I talk
about so much with my mom
and dad did for me as well.
Did they do a great job
in practical optimism?
Like did you have like that
optimism like I can do anything
but were they great at
not creating delusion?
- Yes, very good at it.
- Right, because isn't that,
is that your perspective on that?
Like to me, what is so fascinating is
the current state of parenting,
the reason we have 8th
place trophies is we took
you can do anything, but we
created fake environments.
We eliminated accountability.
And that's why we're
skewed the other way now.
And to me it's the balance of,
I call it practical optimism, right.
Or just like a limit,
when you tell your kid
you can do anything I
think where the parent
really needs to be thoughtful
is when that kid then goes
and sings at a talent show and sucks shit,
you can't tell them they're Beyonce.
(Sampson laughs)
- [Sharlee] Right.
- You can't because what
a lot of people are doing
is you didn't win this talent show
but it was the judge's fault.
It was a bad night.
They like start creating excuses at scale
and now you have 23 year
olds who enter the world
full of excuse framework.
- Well, I mean a really interesting story
is that an early age
Derek went off to school
and said his dream was to become
shortstop for the New York Yankees.
- [Gary] Is that true?
- He had teachers, this
is 8th grade I believe,
he had teachers that said to my parents
that you need to put real
thoughts into his head.
And my parents turned around and said,
in our mind he has real thoughts.
He has to work.
- [Gary] Was he good at
baseball at that point?
- No, he wasn't great.
- [Gary] Really?
- But it was he has to
work very, very hard
and they told him that.
They said, if this is what you wanna do,
you can accomplish it,
but it is gonna be very,
very hard for you to get there.
You're gonna have to
work really, really hard
and put your all into it.
So that's where you have to be realistic.
It is a possibility, but
you're gonna have to work hard.
- My, and the way he says it,
my six and three quarters year old son
is obsessed with basketball.
And he talks about it, he talks
like me, 24/7 every second.
After two weeks of vacation just now,
like my music teacher in first
grade called me motor mouth
and I'm watching it my face.
But he already in the last
six months I've got him into
like he already knows
that he will never dunk.
Right, as a kid and the
little basket in your house
you're dunking like crazy.
And six months ago, I was
like, bro, you will never dunk.
He cried, he was devastated.
Like for a week it was
like tormenting him.
But he is now taking so
many fucking jump shots
and he's like do you
think I'll be in the NBA?
And I'm like I don't think so.
But if you work ridiculously hard
and miraculously become the first person
that can hit jump shots from half court.
Because I think your 5'10",
the likelihood of your life
is going to be a
challenge on the evolution
of like everybody being
seven feet in the NBA.
I just believe in that shit.
- But on the flip side, Gary.
Is there an opportunity to
show him those who were shorter
than six foot and made it?
- He's all about, he
thinks he's Steph Curry.
He already knows who Spud
Webb is, of course, there is.
- But he's also using what he has.
So he's using his
ability, if he can't dunk,
then he's like gonna--
- Well, it's really interesting
it's like all I talk to him about
is jump shooting and left hands.
Like if he's gonna be any prayer
of like a decent D3 basketball player,
like he better fucking shoot his ass off
and better have a ridiculous left hand.
You know what I mean,
like you know so like
it's just this conversation
which is like do not create delusion.
However, what caught my attention
when you were going there is
when your parents tell you
you can do anything
everybody who's accomplished
something remarkable
basically either had that
or such the reverse that
they were like fuck you
that it drove them.
But that person tends to get there
and be unhappy versus the
person that, you know,
and so there's a positive framework.
Nonetheless, how about you?
- My state where I grew
up, you're asking how?
- Yeah, what kind of kid were you?
I love origins, I'm really
big on comic book number one.
Like the next series of questions for me
is gonna be predicated on
where did you grow up, how?
You know like it helps me understand
how you got to "The Stuff", it helps me,
it helps Andy pick the
next couple of questions.
I'm fascinated with context.
- [Sampson] Right, right, got you.
- So where were you born and
what kind of kid were you?
- Yeah, I mean I was born in New Jersey.
- [Gary] Where?
- Norton, New Jersey.
- [Gary] I love it.
- Yeah, Norton, New Jersey.
- [Gary] I grew up in Edison.
- Okay, oh yeah, I went
to school at Rutgers,
they're not too far.
- [Gary] I love it, very close.
- Yeah, so but I was--
- You were a kid.
- [Sampson] I was just an ambitious kid.
You know what, I think I just
had this kind of inner drive.
- [Gary] How old are you?
- When I thought that way?
- [Gary] Right now.
- Oh, 46.
- [Gary] Okay, keep going.
- So I had this inner drive to just really
just become something in life.
I can't really explain it, I
just really believed in life
that I can do it.
I grew up single-parent
home with five siblings
but it was a challenging environment,
but at the same time like I knew
that I wanted to be something.
Now, what that something
was I had no clue.
Of course, I would have
loved to play baseball
but you had that position
was already taken already.
(he laughs)
- Were you a sports kid?
- Yeah, I played baseball, yeah.
I played baseball, basketball.
- So he says, Gary.
- So I say.
(Sharlee laughs)
I have a few articles in
a small paper somewhere.
- Were you good at school?
- Yeah, I was.
I was, school came easy.
You know like I mean it was
something that I enjoyed doing
but it wasn't a cool or
popular thing, right.
(he laughs)
- I'm 43, I came from Jersey,
I know what the vibe was at the time.
- Right, right so you know
you would always sort of hide
or not really brag about that.
- [Gary] Of course, you would
downplay how good you were.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Were good at school?
Like nah, I got a C in.
- Right, right, yeah, yeah.
No, like I got a 95, right.
(Gary laughs)
And so, it just was this
drive to become something
and to achieve something in life.
And just kind of moving along
and as life took me it
just became an opportunity
or opportunity presented
itself to go to medical school
and to become a doctor.
Now, I didn't know what
the hell a doctor did
besides pediatricians and
giving shots and everything.
I didn't know the details
and so I just went for it
because it was something more than
what I had in front of me.
- It intuitively felt like
a proper step forward.
- Right and I enjoyed helping people
and I will always have a job.
So let me go for it.
(he laughs)
- Understood and how,
and in that career path
have you maintained the same passion?
You know obviously you
know speaking and writing,
your scratching other things
that you know you're passionate about.
You know a lot of people
watch and listen to this
are attracted to my
message because I think,
back to you can do anything
but it has to be practical,
what has happened you know three
of us are far closer in age
than a lot of people in this room
and a lot of people that are watching.
We did not grow up with a mature internet
that actually allowed us
to have unlimited options
in perpetuity around our core interests
and that is what's happening now.
So, I guess the reason
I'm asking you that is
I think there's a lot of
people who are watching
who ebb and flow in the
passion of the career choice
they've given and when they're in the dip
they're thinking about
should I start my side hustle or thing.
Have you know, I'm just very
curious about what you're doing
with this and what your career is.
It's a very fun question for me to ask.
Have you maintained that love for it?
Has it never fully been there
because it was the opportunity to win
and advance has it ebbed and flowed?
How is your love for
that profession navigated
over the last 20 years?
- Yeah, that's a very good question.
I think it does or it
has ebbed and flowed,
in the sense that I enjoy medicine
but I also enjoy speaking.
I also enjoy writing books.
Like this is the 5th
book that I've written.
So, I enjoy the
progression of what's next.
The evolution which is unknown.
Because you really don't know.
You know your passion is to
achieve and to be successful
and it might be within a career
aspect of what you're doing
but at the same time I
enjoy the aspect of life.
Of seeing what sort of presents
itself as the next thing.
You don't often know what that is.
But you just kind of follow the flow
of just applying your formula of success
and seeing it grow and develop.
So, yeah, practicing medicine
and being an ER physician
and saving lives and
rescuing people from--
- How'd it feel the first
time to save somebody's life?
- Oh, it's amazing.
It's like you have your own theme music.
You walk out and it's like--
- Talking about something
I could never do,
the second I would see
any level of like trauma
and blood I would literally faint.
(all laugh)
Seriously.
- [Sampson] And you know what--
- I just walk into hospitals
sometimes and get lightheaded.
Walk in the front door of the hospital.
- So this is the beauty.
(all laugh)
But, yeah, the beauty about life is like
the first time I saw a surgery
I lost my lunch in the scrub sink.
- [Gary] You did?
- Yeah, and so I'm in college
and I'm like okay I
chose the wrong career.
I like shit like how I'm
gonna you know fix this?
- And did like everybody else laugh
like it was a right of passage?
Did like some mentor come to you
and be like, don't worry I did that, too?
Or they were just laughing at
you or how did that go down?
- The nurse is, "You gotta
go, you gotta get out."
She kicked me out of the OR.
- [Gary] There's no
joking around in the OR.
I get that.
- Yeah, but that's what I'm saying
like this is what I think sometimes
hinder us as people is
that we go after something
we believe in and we
sort of receive a message
that this isn't for me
or it's too challenging.
- A micro adversity we take it as a macro.
- Right, that's right.
You grow this monster in your mind
to be bigger than what it
is and you don't pursue it
and then, boom it's like now
you're not reaching your level.
- Can we talk about this?
I don't know if you cover it in the book.
Actually there's two things.
Two things, one if you got phone numbers,
YouTube, Facebook we're about to do calls.
Two, I want you to give
me five bullet points
of like takeaways for the book
'cause I want everybody to buy it.
But before we get into that,
you know we're here because you
and I have hung out a
couple of times and we vibed
and I'm like, oh shit, we
see the world the same way.
So I've been excited about
this but excited to meet you.
So I'm leading the
witness a little bit here
but this micro failure as a
macro, how much do you think
the current state of demonizing failure
in our society early on
leads to enormous issues
or vulnerabilities to
what we're referring to
Like do you, let me ask
it in a different way.
Do you believe that we need to start
beating a drum of, especially
at a parenting level,
to start really embracing
failure much earlier
which then won't make somebody
who loses their lunch.
There are actual people on
Earth who lost their lunch
put in all that time and
effort into medical school,
lost their lunch, went
home, called mommy and daddy
and decided to become a lawyer.
- Right, but then they
become that lawyer, too,
what they need to know
is that they're gonna hit
that same point in a
different way on that path.
- [Gary] Bingo.
- And that's where we're
shortchanging our kids.
It's like failure is a part of success.
You have to fail at
some point at something.
You're going to.
Because when you're,
what's happening too, Gary,
is they're not just
changing their careers,
a lot of people are going off to college
and they've been told this whole time,
oh, you're about to fail, let
me go and do something else.
And they don't realize that when they go
and do that other thing,
they're gonna get to a point
where they fail at something.
And people are jumping out of windows.
I mean they're going off to college
and they cannot manage once mommy
and daddy aren't around them anymore.
- Yep, or another version of that,
I see people who are
on their third version
of college 'cause they only
wanna stay in that environment.
That and the NBA and doctor and lawyer,
and I'm like you fucking
love practice, bro.
(both laugh)
I had a friend who at 39 he's like, Gary,
I've got these 76 diplomas and
he can like started consuming
and he's like a friend
from back in the day
and he's like what do you think?
And I'm like you love practice.
What do I think?
I think you're 39 years
old and you love practice.
- Yeah, you have to take flight.
- I'm like you have 17 beautiful diplomas
in an office you have done shit.
You haven't played one fucking game.
Sorry, I get excited.
It was an emotional meeting.
It's like what do I think?
I think it's as obvious as shit.
(Sharlee laughs)
Right?
- [Sampson] Yeah, yeah.
- I not only wanna make
failure an equal to success
I actually wanna celebrate failure as,
I've said this a lot in
a lot of different ways.
You wanna hear something crazy
actually to make this very meta?
Charlie Hayes catches a ball in 1996,
the Yankees win the World Series
and I have not watched
a full Yankee game since
and I grew up a massive
New York Yankees fan.
The New York Rangers
won the '94 Stanley Cup
right across the street there,
and I never watched another.
I literally stopped watching my teams
after they win the championship for ever.
I'm so about the failure and the process.
The reason I love the Jets so much
is how disaster they are.
(both laugh)
I'm loving the Knicks now.
This is real good now.
You know, and I think maybe I
and actually not maybe, I
think I over skew that way.
Like if you really watch
me as an entrepreneur
something nobody in the outside
who's watching right now,
only Marc Yudkin, my
lawyer, my financial people,
I do so many things to sabotage myself.
Or like I put kindness over success.
Or many other things,
because I love losing.
I genuinely am not kidding.
When I, back to growing up in Jersey
and those kind of places,
going to a pickup basketball
game, picking teams
and losing the first
game was always my dream.
Because I loved the feeling
of trying to win the second game.
I enjoy the feeling of
trying to win a second game
of pickup basketball or
a, I liked tennis a lot
and I was good at it.
And one of the reasons I was good at it
was I had a ridiculous
record of winning the second
and third set in comparison
to almost anybody else
on my team or like the coach had seen.
'Cause I actually believe
what I'm about to say.
I think I actually threw
the first set subconsciously
not, you know, because I enjoy adversity.
- But see that's exactly it.
So you are good with you living
in an uncomfortable space.
- No, no I'm fucking great.
(Sampson laughs)
(both laugh)
I always say great.
I love the feeling of, whether I'm great
or good at it, no, no, it's my most,
like as a matter of fact,
even the way I carry myself
cursing or things of that
nature, I've come to learn
recently, last five, three, two years.
Oh, fuck I enjoy being
misunderstood up front.
I love the great unveil.
I love the I told you so.
I love the you didn't think so, fuck you.
And not in like the kind of fucked up way.
More like the showman way.
Like you know what I
like, I like the wink.
I like when I do something
you didn't think I could,
then I look at you and I wink
and it's like a funny thing,
not a fuck you, you know?
More like a (clicking tongue), you know?
What is that?
- To bring you, like to bring it back
and not to just bring it
back to the book, but--
- No, bring it back to the book.
- But what you're saying
and that was why it was so
important when we talked about,
when we interviewed your
people for the this book
was there are so many
stories that you hear about.
And you hear about what happened to them
and then the success of it.
And what we wanted to do
because all of the interesting
stuff is in the middle.
How did they get out of it?
What was it like when
they hit rock bottom?
Like we wanna hear that
they were at a point
where they thought they
could not overcome.
- Sharlee, these are
such macro tough things.
989.8% of the people listening right now
aren't gonna have that level of adversity.
Potentially,
it's their number one.
- It's huge too,
because it's their life.
But also, too, the reason
why we wanted it to be so,
so to the extreme of a tough
situation is how many times
have you watched something on
TV or a story about someone
and you're like wait a minute
if they could get through that
then what I'm dealing with is possible.
- Well, not only that, I will
argue that the single reason
I'm always happy is every single reaction
to everything that happens in
my life that is a negative is
or my wife and kids can get
hit by a car right now and die.
Like I go everytime I've met
with anything that isn't fun
business wise or I go
so extreme and feel it.
That that's exactly right.
Like what people do in
those kind of stories
like I understand that.
That's a framework of a perspective.
- Were you born that way, you feel
or is that something you developed?
- I don't know.
I think I was born that way.
'Cause I absolutely believe in like DNA.
You know, but I think environment.
You know I was very aware that
my mom lost her mom at five
and my dad lost his dad
at 16 since I was six.
I can tell you that.
Like very aware.
I can tell you from seven to
nine I had 15, 20 times a year
nightmares that my family
was going back to Russia
for a family reunion and the plane crashed
and I was the only one
with one random family member each time,
it was always different that survived
and we had to walk through the snow
like Rocky you know in Rocky Four.
So clearly, like death of my family
and like that kind of stuff
has always been a framework
and I don't know I feel like I was born
with certain thoughtfulness
and meta macro shit.
But I also think the
fact that both my parents
lost a parent before they were 16
probably played as a narrative in my mind.
- Yeah, it also sounds
like you embraced the fear.
- Yeah, bro, and honestly a lot of like
not being able to speak English
and going and, you know a
story I rarely ever tell
is when, you know I don't
even talk about Dover.
I lived in Dover for a year
before we moved to Edison.
I always talk about
Queens, think about this,
think about what you guys
are hearing right now.
I would go Queens to Edison.
Truth it was Queens to
Dover for a year to Edison.
I don't even know why and you
know not that it was so bad.
But there's one real
story I will never forget.
I go outside and I can't speak English
and these six kids, and I was five,
these six kids made me
drink piss out of Pepsi can.
And I think about it so much.
Because I can feel this
second, 37 years later,
exactly how I felt and how I felt was
you fuckers are confused.
You're laughing and you think you've won.
You have no idea how
this is gonna play out.
And that, wasn't taught.
- [Sampson] Right.
- I don't think.
I don't know what my mom
and dad were doing in Russia
for those first four years,
but I can't believe that
that's what I, you know
I didn't think about
that until like maybe 10 years ago.
That's crazy that that's what I thought.
Because as we know extreme bullying
and picking on leads the
masses into a very dark place.
It lead me into a very great place.
Which was I'm gonna learn
how to speak English.
I'm gonna fucking dominate
and I'm gonna one day tell
this story on my podcast.
You know like that kind of thing?
- Yeah, no I mean.
And that's exactly, I mean it's two ways
obviously, that you can
sort of meet the challenge
and rise above or you can
let the challenge destroy you
and surrender to it.
And obviously, you did
the thing of rising above.
I mean that's exactly what--
- So how much of this has to do
with you giving a fuck about
other people's opinions?
- I mean some of it has to do with that.
But it's also how you perceive it.
You know how you sort of internalize it.
And so, yeah, other people's opinions
even though sometimes you say
oh, it doesn't matter it does.
- No, no, I'll be honest
with you intuitively
and obviously you've done
more work than I have.
I think that plays a lot into it.
I think people you know take an L
and it's actually other people's booing,
especially maybe the parent,
like the top five people that
is really what scares them.
That if nobody knew about your loss,
would it really matter?
It's kind of like the tree in the forest.
Like at the end of the day,
like when I lose I don't have
an ability to give a fuck
what my parents, my wife, my
kids or my best friends think.
And in that, is the great liberation
of being able to do anything.
- But you were raised in a different time.
So you have to remember we
are raising kids now a days,
I mean not me personally,
but that they can't lose.
That they get an award.
- [Gary] You're preaching.
- Right, so if they have it
then they are never allowed
the opportunity to say they lost.
So why wouldn't they run from failure
every time they see it?
- You're preaching.
Questions, let's do it, Andy.
I get it.
I can't get off of 8th place trophies.
I can't.
(Sampson laughs)
I can't get off of it.
I am completely and utterly convinced
that a stunning majority
of the mass depression,
anxiety, fear and jumping out of windows
is has nothing to do with social media
or iPads it has everything
to do with parents
that wanted to overcoddle their kids
which created zoo animals.
(phone ringing)
You take these animals from the Bronx Zoo
and put them in the natural wild
and they're dead in eight seconds.
- [Answering Machine] Hi, this Alice,
I'm sorry I couldn't
answer your call right now.
- Sorry, Alice, next.
I believe that.
I believe we have an entire
generation of zoo animals.
And I think the second those
animals understand they are
instead of, this is where it's funny,
so I go after the parents
but then to the kids I go,
cool, but instead of being
upset at your parents forever
now you take over and fucking
own it and reformulate.
- Right.
- Accountability.
- [Sharlee] Right.
- You took the trophy.
(phone ringing)
It's funny a friend's parents
said the kid didn't take a trophy.
I think he was a hockey tournament,
didn't take the third place trophy
and they were like mad at him
and there was a whole thing.
I said, that fucking kid's gonna win.
- [Automated Voice] I'm sorry the person
you are trying to reach,
- You know what I mean?
- has a voicemail box that has
not been set up yet.
- Why are these taking L's left
and right on the phone call.
(Sampson laughs)
This kid did not take the bronze medal.
- [Sharlee] He is not afraid of failing.
- [Sampson] That's right,
at least he's trying.
(Sharlee laughs)
- Alice?
- [Alice] Yes.
- You called back?
- [Alice] Yes, I pressed the wrong button
when the phone rang, I'm sorry.
- No apologies needed.
Where are you from and please say hello?
- [Alice] Hi, how are you?
- [Sampson] Hello.
- [Alice] I'm from Miami, Florida
and thank you for taking
my call by the way.
I wanna talk to you about
because it's just like I
happened to get on YouTube
and there you guys were and
it just hit home so hard.
I'm almost 48.
I grew up in a family
that migrated from Cuba.
Success story, great, very supportive.
I grew up knowing that I
could overcome anything
and I was very, very successful
until I got ill a few years ago.
Got out of that and my dad got sick
and I've been dealing
with all this stuff now
and all of sudden I feel like
I don't know what happened to the old me.
I'm paralyzed, I don't know
what I'm doing with my life.
All I know is that I'm
just getting day by day.
You know I have the financial means.
I have everything, but
that's not important.
I'm missing my drive again, my
motivation to wanna do stuff.
I fell like paralyzed.
- I understand.
Thoughts guys or questions for Alice
that might be able to build context?
- Yeah, I think, Alice, whatever it is.
It's something there, some trepidation
that you're facing and I don't
know specifically what it is,
but it's sort of embracing that
and accepting it and dealing with the pain
of whatever that may be.
And it's also, then formulating
strategies to overcome
and to sort of find that
drive within yourself
whether it's exercise, yoga, meditation,
reading, you know, sort of--
- You're getting into
tactics that become tangible
doing that become gateway
drugs to the unlock.
- There you go, exactly.
And I think that's--
- [Alice] You're absolutely right.
- [Gary] Alice, can I ask you a question?
- [Alice] Yes.
- Alice, something I've seen
a lot of immigrants can I,
do you think that maybe
that you overvalued
financial success given the framework
which would make a ton of sense.
And then when you dealt
with your own health issues
or dad what ended up happening
at this young of an age
you're like wait a
minute, fuck money, health
and happiness and maybe the reframe
of what you thought success was
is what you might be dealing with?
- [Alice] Well, you're
right because you know what
I realized when I got sick
I couldn't find the answer
and there was no dollar
amount in the world
that could find me the
doctor or the whatever,
so I felt like how can I, you
know if this is so successful,
made all this money, have all this support
and I can't get better.
And then my rock, which is my dad,
I come out of this and now he's sick
and I'm like, oh my gosh,
you know what I mean.
I can' fix it.
- You know it's funny
I've got crazy goosebumps
because I was listening
to you and I was like
so I said something like
five times on vacation
the last two weeks and
the first week back.
We're now Thursday, I was
in LA the first three days
had different business meetings.
And eight times, 'cause I counted,
eight times in the last
three days in business
I said I'm starting to question
if I'm driven by money at all.
I've always known that it
wasn't the biggest thing.
I'm starting to get scared that
I don't give a fuck at all.
I'm aware that I, you know
think back to I love the chase.
Like I love chasing the
Jets, not buying the Jets.
And then equally I don't
give a fuck about money
which is a problem if you
wanna buy the New York Jets
'cause it's gonna cost 4 billion dollars.
But as you were talking,
Alice, I was like fuck
and this is why, I just
wanna chase happiness
and I put health on a crazy pedestal
and I think you just might be going
through a maturity mentally, Alice.
I actually think this is gonna unlock
the greatest thing ever.
I making assumptions and
alluding to things that look,
parents tend to pass before their kids.
When you have an emotional rock
and that big of an emotional relationship
you fear that loss so, so, so much
but to be very, very
frank with you, Alice,
as you were talking I was
getting happy not sad.
I actually think you're just leveling up.
I think the reason you were happy before
was you were trying to
win a very short game
which was money, which
came naturally to you
because of lack of fear and talent
and skills and hard work.
I just think you're evolving
and I think you're gonna
start going for fulfillment.
- [Alice] You're right.
You know what I'm listening to you talk
and I'm thinking you know what,
you're absolutely right.
Now it's like where do I get
my juice, my adrenaline now?
- I think you're gonna get it
from impacting other humans.
I genuinely think humans
have either selfish
or selfless behavior.
I think that I'm happy because
I have so much of both.
I'm so ambitious for me
and I have so much want
and need to leave a legacy
and that's why if you look
at how I'm rolling over
the last three years,
especially, it's so obvious,
right which is why people take
different hot takes on me.
You know like I'm the genius and best.
I'm a narcissist and the worst.
Like I get it because I'm
pulling so hard at both
and I think what you did
was you pulled so hard
for you, financial success,
now you have this in between phase
where you're starting to get recalibrated
on what actually matters.
My guess, when I run into
you in a airport in 16 years,
is you were so right, I
started this nonprofit,
I started this for-profit, nonprofit.
I started this school, I did
this thing with these 50 women.
I have no idea, but I have a
very funny feeling I'm right.
- [Alice] Wow, that's great.
Thank you for telling me
that because you know what,
it really opened up, you know,
a new seeing glass, if you will.
But yeah, you're right,
that's, I mean I've always said
giving back is the best way to
you know come out of things.
But I--
- But, Alice, you're gonna love this.
You're gonna love this.
The way that you were
successful in business
and people talked about
ideas and you laughed at them
and you said, yeah, but
it's about the execution.
People talk about giving
back is the best thing ever
and they don't give back.
- [Alice] That's exactly it.
That's exactly it.
They might do it with money or a check,
but not with themselves.
- Bingo, you know how much fun it is
for me to write a $25,000
check to a charity
then sit down with some
kid for 30 minutes?
The minutes matter to me.
That's giving the fuck back.
- [Alice] That is more
important than money
when it comes to these
things, you know what I mean?
- Well especially, listen, Alice,
a lot of people are listening right now
and they're saying easy
for them, they have it.
You know and that's true, by the way,
like a lot of things in life are easier
once you've checked
one of the boxes you've wanted.
You know a lot of people who gave money--
- [Alice] Yeah, you just think
it's gonna give you something,
but it doesn't.
- Correct.
- [Alice] You think it's gonna
fill a void and it doesn't.
- Correct, a lot of people, say to people
easy you know for this person
to say, they have money.
And then I say to them yeah,
but look how happily married
you are, that person isn't.
So you have happiness and love.
Like you know there's just
so, like everyone's judging
without understanding everyone's
got their shortcomings.
And the reality is we've
all got our process.
I think the serendipity
of life has created
two data points for you that
reframed your perspective
and the reason you're
struggling to get it back
is you will never, ever again,
care about the money
the way you did before.
It won't happen.
- [Alice] No, it's true.
I downsized my car because
I don't really care.
Just everything changed.
And now I'm like, wait
a minute, you're right.
You're absolutely right.
It just, when you know
you can have seven jets,
you don't want seven jets.
- 100,000 fucking percent.
Thanks, Alice.
- [Alice] You know, thank
you, thank you, bye-bye.
- Does it get you guys pumped
when you hear the clarity in her voice?
I was like wondering what
you guys were thinking,
you know sometimes when you
know you talk to somebody
and you're like they do not get it.
- [Sampson] Yeah, she got
it, she definitely did.
She got it, yeah.
- You know, right.
I was curious what you guys were thinking.
- Oh, yeah, she got it.
Actually it was, you
awakened something in her.
You could tell that she was
like, wow, somebody gets
where I at and understands
what I'm going through.
- It was funny when she was
talking like I got this one.
You know like sometimes you just know.
Sometimes you just know.
While Andy's dialing this next number
and before you hit it Andy
what are two macro thoughts
about what's in the book
for the audience that
might bring them value?
- Well, I mean one of the things
that we talk about in the book
is just having a good
support system around you
and that doesn't have to be your family.
- Say that second part
one more time, super loud.
- It doesn't have to be your family.
- [Gary] Just do it again.
(Sampson laughs)
- It does not have to be your family.
Because I think that's where
people check out right away.
Well I didn't come from
a supportive family.
My family's not here and
so I'm not gonna have
that support system, but
sometimes it's not your family
it's a friend who's just
there to kick you in the butt,
you know and say look you can do this.
Get off your butt like it's time to go.
It's okay to grieve.
It's okay to be down
and it's okay to feel like
you failed at something,
but now it's time to get up
and do what you should do.
- And you know you're motivating me.
Like I'm literally sitting
here thinking about this a lot.
You're saying something so awesome
and you're saying it's okay to fail.
It's okay to grieve and no joke,
what's going through my
head is, like I was thinking
about literally you're talking
and Andy's surrounding me and I was like,
it's so funny how the brain works,
I'm picturing me and Andy
hanging out somewhere
and like what's coming out of my mind
is forget about it's okay to grieve,
it's okay, it's more like
no, dude, this is good.
This is fucking awesome.
Like I just want people to
embrace their scarlet letters.
Like I wish I had
that fucking scarlet
letter from that book.
I would have fucking
supermanned that shit.
Fuck you.
Like I wanna make it
awesome, not adequate.
Like we, to your point, where
we are in society right now
is like let's take it from
negative to it's okay.
Right, we're having this
great mental awareness thing
of like it's okay.
Let's take away the stigma
and I'm on some shit of like
fuck the stigma, adversity
is the foundation
to happiness and success.
- [Sampson] Yeah, you're saying--
- You're lucky.
- You run towards--
- [Gary] You're lucky, you're
lucky your mom's fucked up.
(both laugh)
I'm gonna say it one more time.
- I don't know if it's that, but yes.
(all laugh)
- Sampson, Sampson, Sampson I really wanna
throw a fun challenge
because I'm appreciating
that I have you guys
to bounce this off of.
I wanna argue this in a fun way.
I am convinced that the things
we've alluded to earlier,
the perfect situation
that has so much resources
and so much good that
it's overcorrected so much
to make you a zoo animal is
far more vulnerable right now
than the person from a
fucked up environment
or person, like I'm
telling you I can sense it.
Because what the Internet's done to us.
- [Sampson] Yeah.
- You see where I'm going is, look at you,
you're an African-American
male 46, like I don't,
I didn't get into the details
but like whatever the
circumstances are of Rutgers
and medical, you know,
your natural talents,
school came easy to you, not to me.
Your work and all that
stuff but like fuck man,
do people understand that we don't need
the government grants, the
lucky or just valid test score,
the cosign from somebody
that you stumbled upon.
Like everybody that
needed somebody to unlock,
the gatekeepers are gone, the
Internet's the gatekeeper.
The end.
- [Sampson] That's their validation, yeah.
- The audience can be the validation.
Not the luckiness that their
next door neighbor's friend
was like, you know it's crazy.
- But I also think, too.
Oh, are you calling?
(phone ringing)
Okay, I also think that,
too we're in a situation now
where when you say there's
this perfect environment.
I mean we have to realize
that that perfect environment
there's still life.
So I go off to college in my senior year,
I was, I believe I have the
best parents in the world,
they shielded me, they protected me
but they also taught me right from wrong
and to work hard.
But I go off to college and
I get diagnosed with cancer.
They can't control it.
Derek's money can't fix it for me.
I'm out there and I
have to deal with life.
And that's what I'm saying
is that they can have this
perfect environment but life
is still going to hit them.
And they're gonna have to
figure out how to deal,
you know, maneuver it
and it doesn't matter
what their environment
was growing up, as well.
- What about people that are wired like me
which is the number one thing
that would have ruined my life
is if I was the children of me.
As somebody who only wants
to build and this process,
right, like every other normal human
as much as I wanna shield
out other people's opinions
you're still a human.
If I was born into a situation
with all this natural talent,
unlike sports where
you've gotta prove it out
even if your LeBron's kid.
In business it's cloudy
and if I had parents
that had extreme wealth my entire career
would have been I was put
on third and a half base.
You didn't do it
and it would have destroyed my life.
I tell a friends the hood
and the streets all the time,
I know you envy the trust
fund baby who's on a yacht
in Ibiza on Instagram right now.
That kid is fucked, if that kid's a winner
or has any ambition for themselves
that kid is so fucked up
when he goes to sleep you don't even know.
Of course, everybody has their shit.
There is no perfect life.
- [Both] Right.
- I believe that.
I know, I literally believe
that I would be extremely
fucked up as a person
if I was born into
every exact same thing--
- [Eytan] Hello.
- Who's?
- [Andy] Your friend Eytan.
- Eytan, Sugarman, your big bro.
(both laugh)
Oh, wow.
- Hey, babe.
- [Eytan] I love this, love this.
- Ace, I never share your
fucking Instagram stories
but when you gave love to
your little sister here
I had to share it
yesterday about this show.
- [Eytan] I would agree
you never share my Instagram stories.
(others laugh)
- What is your question Mr. Sugarman?
- [Eytan] Well, here's my question,
first of all big love to
everyone in that room.
- [Sampson] Thank you.
- [Eytan] My question is
and this is gonna be serious
and Sharlee you'll be really surprised
by what I'm about to ask.
- [Sharlee] Uh-oh.
- [Eytan] Sharlee and I go back 23 years.
I've never broached this topic with her.
I was there when her diagnosis came
and her brother told me about it.
Shortly thereafter, her brother
and I and another friend, Mike,
flew to Atlanta kinda to be
with her and raise her spirits.
But I've never asked her what,
what her mental spirit
was in terms of acceptance
of the disease, the initial fear
and taking it from, you
know, the fear to the fight.
And what that process was
and how it affected her later success?
That's my question.
- Whew, who knew you
were this deep, Eytan.
(she laughs)
- I'd definitely deny it.
I'd definitely deny.
(both laugh)
Actually I do.
I genuinely believe that
Eytan will go down in history
as a prime example of
what a friend looks like.
I think he's more
talented at being a friend
then almost anybody
I've ever seen in life.
I genuinely believe that.
- [Eytan] Thanks for saying that.
- So to answer your question, Eytan,
first of all thank you
for being a part that team
that came and supported me.
I do remember that weekend very well.
And Eytan's forgetting to
say that he also hosted
my 21st birthday party in New York.
And him and Derek they flew all
my friends in to surprise me
during a snowstorm to lift my
spirits so I appreciate that.
You know it's interesting,
Eytan, because I wrote this book
off of the discussion me and
Sampson had about how I did not
ever really process what was going on.
And I, it was almost like I
was in, not so much denial,
I knew I had to get treatments.
I knew I had to deal
with six months of chemo,
but I stayed in school and
decided I was gonna continue
commuting back and forth
to Jersey, or New York,
to do chemo at Sloan Kettering
because I didn't wanna stop college.
I didn't wanna leave my friends.
I didn't wanna move back home.
So, it wasn't until a few
years ago when we decided
before we decided to write the book,
that I was kind of woken up by Sampson.
I don't know if you wanna jump in,
but we were just having
a conversation about it.
We had never talked about
it before and I was like--
- And were you guys friends?
Like give us some context for
everybody who's listening.
Why were you having a conversation?
Are you business associates or friends?
- Yeah, we both have our own
foundations, run foundations.
And his foundation honored
me for the work that I do.
- [Gary] And that's how
you got to know each other?
- So I met him and I hired him
and his friends to
speak to all of our kids
in our organization because
their story was so impactful.
- [Gary] Yep, got it.
- And we were on a flight home
from one of our baseball clinics in Tampa
and he started talking
about this book idea.
He had a book idea,
but it was more along the
medical side of things
and I was like, come on Sam,
don't make me read another medical book.
I'll read it to support you
but look, why don't you do something
that everyone can relate to?
And, I don't even remember how
it exactly it was brought up,
but he brought up something
about me going through treatment
and how I was one of these people
who had overcome adversity.
And I said, no, no-no-no,
like I just didn't wanna leave college
and leave my friends and move back home.
Like really, I truly believed that.
- I believe that, yeah.
- I did not want to stop life
and he's like but the fact
that you look at it
that way is so strange.
You know it's not normal that
you just say, oh, cancer,
okay well I'm just gonna
stay in school and finish up
and take a flight back and forth,
which luckily I was fortunate enough,
my family could support me to do that.
But you know it was eye
opening for me to know
that I actually had something
inside of me that would,
that had prepared me to go through that.
And that was why I was on this search
through doing this project to find out
what were those things
that I had inside of me
so that I could use them moving forward,
so that I could teach my son about them
and teach others about it.
Because that was important to
me with our foundation work,
with teaching kids how they do
have these things within them
and a lot of times we suppress them,
we don't even know they exist within us.
- I love it.
Eytan, thanks for such
a great question, bro.
- [Eytan] All right, guys, take care.
- [Sampson] Take care.
- Let's sneak one more in.
Let's sneak one more in.
While Andy's dialing anything
else we wanna talk about
because I wanna get as much context.
- One of the other sort of
ingredients with "The Stuff"
is forge your motivation statement,
which I think is very important.
It's sort of having your
own mantra, I think.
And whatever you're going through life
and where you're going
you need that motivation,
that constant reminder
to keep pushing yourself.
And it should be something very simple.
I use three Ds; dedication,
determination and discipline.
And I feel like that is ironclad
and it can help you to sort of
get you to where you're going.
Cause we are all on this
sort of journey in life.
You know we know our destination.
We all have the same
destination ultimately.
- [Gary] We're all gonna die.
- We're all gonna die.
(both laugh)
- We really wanna figure this out, right.
I feel like if I figure it out,
then I'm the number one guy.
That's how I win.
(both laugh)
- [Sampson] And it's what you do with
that dash in the middle, you know.
- [Gary] Yeah, 100%.
- So it's--
- God, I like that.
The dash, that's fresh.
That feels like something I would say.
(both laugh)
No, I like that.
What are you gonna do with
that dash in the middle?
- So you have to stay motivated
and you have to find that drive--
- You know, something?
I apologize, I don't know
why that just hit me, sorry,
something I didn't I haven't
shared with my audience
or really, even a lot of
people, I think the team knows.
My grandmother passed away
four or five weeks ago
and I've talked about my
grandma publicly here and there
about like being a tough kind of character
and like having empathy for my dad.
But it still is, you know,
and you know what's funny
the dash in the middle hit me so hard,
'cause I spent at that
funeral 98% of my time
looking at all these different tombstones
and just looking at dates.
And just like and like, looking
at that dash in the middle.
You know?
- [Sampson] And that's key and that's it.
- That's the game.
- But that's where your
happiness and your joy
and everything lies is in that journey.
And you know what I think also in life
and now being 46 I started to see
your perspectives are
what your desires are
and what you want changes.
You know it sort of--
- That's the best part.
That's what we did with Alice.
That's the, honestly,
you've heard me say this.
I secretly hope I wake up one day
and don't wanna work ever again
and just do some like fucking weird Yoda
in a fucking mountain shit.
Like this audience gets so big
and that I'm just like
in Peru in some like,
you have to figure, it's like a game
you have to figure out how to find me.
Like if you can find me, I'll
fucking break it down for you.
(Sharlee laughs)
- [Sampson] Right, right,
right, right, right.
- I think about that shit.
- [Sampson] Yoda.
(Sampson laughs)
- I only wanna go, if like
people, you know retirement
that's the being half pregnant.
I'm like I'm either doing
this til like I'm 97
and go like you know or I'm
going fucking weird as shit.
Like weird, like my own
little weird, like weird.
I'm telling you it's
gonna be on the record,
if I decide not to work
every day of my life
until the day I die and
try to win super bowls
and buy the Jets and all that?
I'm gonna go weirder than,
you know some people like Howard Hughes
and these people become recluses?
I'm gonna be the good version of that.
I'm gonna go weird but positive weird.
Not like grow out like
my hair and nails weird.
- [Sampson] I just can't
wait to see the Internet.
- [Gary] More like--
- But he said not the
hair and nails weird.
- [Gary] Not the weird hair and nails.
- You have to have weird
stuff, you have to have it.
- I wanna meet every kid come through.
But I'm gonna challenge you to find me.
(phone ringing)
Not some Waldo shit.
(Sharlee laughs)
- [Sampson] I can't wait.
- [Andy] Jimmy.
- [Gary] Jimmy.
- [Jimmy] Hello.
- Jimmy, it's Gary Vee.
- [Jimmy] Who?
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Jimmy] Are you kidding me?
- I am not kidding, Jimmy.
- [Jimmy] Oh, my god.
Okay, hey how you doing, man?
- I'm doing really well.
You're on the show please say
hello to Sampson and Sharlee.
- [Jimmy] Hey, how's everybody doing?
- Hello.
- Doing well.
- [Gary] What's your question?
- [Jimmy] Quick question,
yeah, so I've been in
and out of jail my whole
life and I've been,
you know I've started my
new credit repair company.
I've been on probation out here in Chicago
and I can't focus on my
three daughters, my wife
and my business as well as I want to
because of other things
that I've done in the past.
What can I do?
- I've got a thought, but I
know I've been talking too much,
'cause I've been excited
to have you guys here.
Why don't you guys take care of bats
I've got a thought.
- Go ahead.
- And you say you can't
focus on all three?
- He can not focus
because he's dwelling on
what's hanging over his head in his past
and my opinion is he's so over worried
of something that he has no control over,
'cause it's chapter one, two and three.
And the reason chapter four, five
and six can't be successful
is he keeps reading
chapter one, two and three
instead of writing chapter
four, five and six.
- [Jimmy] I love it.
- Oh, that was good.
- [Sampson] Yeah.
- That's a clip.
That was kind of, bro, that's your answer.
That's your answer.
Let me give you something
crazy about society.
- [Jimmy] So, Gary, what
your saying is I need to stop
reading and I need to start writing?
I need to pick up the pen
and put the book down.
- That's right.
What I'm also telling you is, bro,
it's not 1974 in America anymore.
Nobody gives fuck that
you've been to jail.
- [Sampson] Right.
- When I tell you this,
but I hope this is the line
that finally breaks open your life,
you cannot believe what I'm about to say.
Nobody gives a fuck.
The stigma, as a matter
of fact, I like you more.
Now, you might, you know,
mainly because you've been in
and out so I'm making an assumptions
that it hasn't been the most
extreme shit, you know like.
You just been doing dumb shit,
not like fucking all time I hate you shit.
So I weirdly think that you're
using the excuse of your past
to not let yourself be
successful and that's why,
everybody comes up with some excuse.
Building a business is hard, motherfucker.
You understand?
And so--
- [Jimmy] It's not how to fucking love it,
I just can't put the fucking time in.
I built that wall, that can't wall,
saying I can't do this, I can't do that.
It's just that I'm dwelling
on the other commitments
that I have to make to
the State of Illinois.
So you're right, it's an excuse.
- Yeah, dude,
- Instead of actually
getting up in the morning.
- Listen you know, that's it, bro.
Jimmy, you know what's amazing about life?
Bro, you did that shit,
that's why Illinois has a
fucking vig on your head,
guess what, that's what you gotta do.
- [Sampson] And it too, pass.
You know you gotta keep
in mind, it will pass.
But you do have to
work, as Gary mentioned,
towards your next chapters of
life and you have your family.
You have your career.
I mean, you have already achieved,
so just embrace that aspect,
the positive side of it.
Don't let the negative or
what has happened in the past
that has shaped you believe it or not.
It has shaped you
- In a good way.
- to be where you are.
I mean I'll share a real
quick personal story.
I did, I was locked up incarcerated,
as well, as a juvenile.
And you know, thankfully.
- That Newark life.
- [Sampson] That--
(he laughs)
(all laugh)
And I just got to wink from
Gary so I know I'm doing good.
(all laugh)
- The wink is good.
The wink is good.
I love to--
- The wink is good.
And you know, and if I wasn't 17 1/2
my story would have been
written differently.
So that didn't stop me.
- Let's talk about that for 14 seconds,
then I wanna get back to you.
Literally, half a year.
- [Sampson] Half a year 17 1/2.
- What happened?
You were 18.
- Oh, I would have been
an adult, I would have
had an adult charge.
I would have a sort of you
know real true federal number
or number that would
have prevented me from--
- [Gary] Medicine or other things.
- Yeah, from becoming a doctor.
And this all environmentally
shaped how I grew up
and being surrounded by
what I was surrounded by.
But at the same time,
instead, to add to your point,
instead I that sort of sending a message
that I could not do
it, it sent the message
that I had to get on this crusade
and make these next steps and write this--
- [Jimmy] You know I might
be sick of the crusades.
Gary said a lot of things
that really hit home to a lot of people.
And one of them to me is
being, I'm always the story.
You know the one they look at around town,
saying wow, he came from nothing.
He had absolutely nothing.
His parents are dead and he ain't got this
how the fuck does he do it?
But then after about eight months
of just nonstop fucking
work I give up, right.
I just say I get to fuck it.
So I'm like I'm gonna take two weeks off.
And two weeks is two months
and I'm fucking broke again.
- Um-hm, I think that something
that I'm obsessed with brother,
is and this would make
so much sense to me.
This is why I tell people
to chase something they like
versus chasing the money.
One of the reasons you may be giving up
is you might have the
talent to make the money
in eight months that a
lot of people admire,
the problem is you don't fucking love it.
- [Jimmy] I like to cook.
I found my passion.
I'm 33 years old and been in
sales my entire fucking life.
I'm phenomenal in sales.
I'll stand by everything I say.
I fucking hate it.
I like to cook.
I like to see romances you
know coming into the restaurant
on their date night and seeing them happy
with the fucking meal I provide them.
I don't wanna sell people shit no more.
Everything I fucking do is a sale.
I get that.
- So now let me give you a
really good piece of advice.
If you just get patient,
which is hard when you have
Illinois' vig on your head.
When you've got three kids that want shit.
When you want shit.
When your wife wants shit.
When people are watching.
With all the things in life.
But brother, if you get slow
and patient, how old are you?
- [Jimmy] 33.
- You're so fucking young.
This is so fun, this is so fun for me.
Bro, if you slow this the fuck down,
you can cook and make tons of money
for the rest of your life,
'cause you've got sales
talent, which is a gift.
And you can cook your fucking
ass off for the next 75 years.
All you have to do is not value
money for the next 36 months
and eat shit to build the foundation
to make the cooking make the money.
- [Jimmy] Yes, I don't
give a fuck about money.
Money never motivated me.
I wanna do my passion,
but like you said I got a 16 year old,
a seven year old and a
three month year old.
And when you're 33 it's
a little difficult here
with four girls in the house at all times
I gotta take care of.
- I get it.
So now you have to have different
conversations with them.
This is where you can bless
them when you're like, hey, fam,
here's where we're going.
We're all gonna collectively
eat shit for three years.
If you don't like it, tough shit.
We're gonna eat shit
collectively for three years.
It's gonna shape, you
so you're not a loser
and dad's always providing
for you, so you're gonna win
and dad's gonna get into a good place
so he can do it forever.
So let's all huddle up
on three, say eat shit.
(both laugh)
And for the next the next three years
I'm gonna build bricks
which are maybe not gonna allow
you to get the new supremes
or maybe we can't go to
the best hotel at Disney
or maybe you're not gonna get
those fucking fly Fila dad shoes
but here's what's gonna happen,
we're gonna fucking do it
and we're gonna win forever
instead of up and down, up and down.
I build for myself and I admire in others
when they've created a
framework that makes them play
and with happiness in perpetuity.
Not up down, up down
and everybody's out here
up down, up downing it.
- [Jimmy] You're doing
great until you're not.
Right, I'm sick of it.
- Because you're up downing it, bro.
You're making, you've created a framework
that's not sustainable,
it's creating profit to
allow you to kind of achieve
this overhead of four people in Illinois
but then you burn out.
What you need to do is go the other way
and eat shit for three years
to foundationally build
your restaurant chain,
franchisee, one-off high
end place or cooking model
or cooking school or there's
a million things you can do.
But you're gonna have to eat shit
for three years financially,
which is tough for the 16 year old,
tough for you and your wife, I get it.
But it is the only answer for you
to create something in perpetuity.
- [Jimmy] Absolutely, you know
what my wife's gonna kill me,
if I stay on the phone, but I feel blessed
to be able to talk to you today, Gary
and everyone there with you.
- Thank you, bro.
Hope you have a great day.
- [Jimmy] All right have a good one.
- Bye-bye.
Guys, parting thoughts
and then you get to ask
the question of the day.
Any question that you want
answered from the audience.
Parting thoughts?
- Ooh, no, I mean first of all
thank you so much for having us.
We appreciate it.
My parting thoughts would
just be that our goal,
we talked a lot about giving back
and doing things that make you happy,
but I truly believe
that by living your life
to do things for others
and to look at those
that are coming behind you is
something that is fulfilling.
And it's, a lot of people
don't realize that.
They think that if they have
a ton of money to give back
that that's what's gonna,
you know you just give back
and it has to do with money.
And you talk a lot about giving your time.
And I do feel like that's
a huge part of success.
I feel like it's
something that's necessary
in order to overcome
things is to find a way
to make it about more than just yourself.
And so that would be
probably my parting thought.
- [Gary] I love it, Sam?
- Yeah, I mean agree.
Thanks for having us.
But I also feel that just
the evolution of time
and how we progress is
the goal now in life
or the goal of life as
it stands this moment,
is to really follow your purpose.
Find your calling, what it stands for
and everything else
will sort of come along.
I think our generation
growing up it was always
go after the career,
become this, become that.
- [Gary] Doctor, lawyer.
- Yeah, and I think you know--
- [Gary] It's changed so much.
- It's changed so much and
technology has really helped
with that, as well, just
the acceptance of it all.
- [Gary] I know, it's
the framework of why.
- Right, it's the framework of why.
And it all starts with why, right.
So I mean I think you have
to find what that why is,
not you're what, and really pursue it.
And you know that's really
what I'm learning now
at this stage of life.
- You know what I liked that
you brought to the table here
and I'm curious if it's in the book
'cause I think it'll bring
value, 'cause I'm very macro.
I thought you were pressing
the whole way in this podcast tactics.
Like create your motto,
create like you know,
I like to go super-macro and
then tell everybody watch me
I'm giving you my tactics and my actions.
You have to watch me differently
but I'm gonna talk macro.
I thought you did a really
good job and multiple times
going into and then do
this and then do this
and I think doing really matters.
Back to that joke I made earlier
about like you love practice.
- And that's the structure of the book
is eleven core elements.
And that's what we try to
do is walk people through
how to do it, but don't tell them
how to apply it to their own lives.
- And I think the tactics
is just bullet points.
You're right, again you tell your story,
but just like running a marathon,
you get a cup of water, along the course.
But you have to run the marathon yourself.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
What's your question of the day?
- Ooh, you go 'cause that's a tough one.
This is a question for the audience?
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause then they'll fill in
in the Comments section their answers.
Which might be like a good research
and development thing for you.
Maybe something you're curious about.
- Yeah, I think the question
is what is your fear
and how do you overcome your fear?
How do you face your fear?
- So let's actually, I'm
sorry to jump right in,
but we've done this once or twice.
One of the most interesting things
that I've done in my career
as a public figure is this question.
I genuinely believe that when
people actually say their fear
out loud to the world, that
they've taken back the leverage.
I really believe it.
And it's super hard.
It's as hard as it gets.
You're gonna get a lot of fake answers.
You're gonna get a lot of
second thing that they fear,
third thing they fear,
because the number one
thing they fear is probably
putting out somebody they love, out.
That's the truth.
And that's hard.
Man, I really love that you
said your support system
doesn't have to be your family.
I wish people knew how
to put into the proper
like department their family.
Because they could have
such a healthier life
with their family and
be happier themselves.
Instead of them being miserable
and hating their family,
they could accept their
family for their shortcomings
and they can be happier.
- Right, and also, too,
they're not blaming.
'Cause see I think we look
at other people's lives
and we say, oh well,
they succeeded my life
doesn't look exactly like that
so I'm not gonna succeed in the same way.
- It's a lack of accountability.
Even your parents who
had the biggest outcome
it's still you.
You've heard this podcast
or this video right now.
Now means it's on you.
Now you've heard it, so it's on you.
Once you take that it gets so good.
Thanks for being on.
- [Sharlee] Thank you.
- Thank you, thank you, Gary.
- On this episode we get deep.
(Sampson laughs)
Awesome that was amazing.